[Música]
ah
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
ahora
transporte
[Música]
alguna vez se han preguntado de dónde
sale la voz de humana
si nuestra voz como es que sale mi voz
casi nadie se pregunta a eso
para mí es sumamente importante mi voz
no sale sola
en este momento mentales hablo necesito
de fuerza de voluntad
así como mi mano no se mueve solo
yo soy el que está moviendo la mano
cada uno mueva su mano
[Aplausos]
se ven bonitos saludando
pero sientan no piensen sientan
y mueve la mano
entonces de dónde sale mi voz no piensen
siete años
[Música]
i
con él
[Música]
i
sí
[Música]
una vez una persona me dijo bueno uno
respira entra por las fosas nasales
llegan a los pulmones los pulmones se
ensanchan se comprimen y el aire sale y
tocan las cuerdas vocales y así sale la
voz pero yo creo que todos entendemos
que es la parte fisiológica nada más no
nos explica de dónde sale mi voz
voy a usar las palabras del maestro
jesús que todos lo conocemos si somos
occidentales claro que hemos oído hablar
de él él dijo esta frase maravillosa
no es
necesariamente lo que entra por la boca
lo que debemos cuidar
sino más bien lo que sale de ella
porque del corazón proviene
porque del corazón proviene es así
sale nuestra voz del corazón cada vez
que hablamos
estamos hablando desde el corazón
[Música]
pues de qué lugar
yo creo que todos en este momento
podemos sintonizarnos con que la mayoría
de las veces cuando salen nuestra voz es
de lugares muy diferentes desde el enojo
desde el dolor desde la tristeza desde
el ego es decir quiero tener razón
quiero que me den la razón quiero opinar
y usamos esta expresión de libre
libertad de expresión
y cómo podríamos tener libertad de
expresión si simplemente decimos
cualquier cosa que se nos ocurre eso no
es libertad de expresión la libertad de
expresión tal vez comience cuando
haciendo
sentimos y pensamos lo que vamos a decir
pero normalmente decimos lo que pensamos
y somos presos de esas palabras y una
vez que decimos una palabra dura el ser
humano inventó pedir perdón
una actividad que usa poco de todas
formas nos cuesta mucho pedir perdón
ese es el ego eso es nosotros queriendo
tener razón pero cuando actuamos desde
el corazón no queremos tener razón
queremos que haya armonía porque la
música porque la música
antes de pensar en música tenemos que
pensar en sonido
el sonido de lo más poderoso que tenemos
piense en esto puede ser que no haya
seres humanos fuera de nuestro planeta
nadie aquí puede comprobarlo nadie puede
asegurar que los hay o que no los hay
pero partamos de que no los hay
quiero que tomen conciencia de esto y lo
que significa
sonido
sonidos y hay
nos creemos muy importantes tenemos un
poco tiempo de estar en este planeta si
vemos la edad del universo si vemos la
edad de nuestro planeta o del sol
sonidos y hay porque todo vibra y si
todo vibra esa energía y si esa energía
es luz el sonido lo que nosotros
llamamos música es color es luz esa
energía mi voz es energía mi voz
construye y si estamos hablando de
educación la educación necesariamente
tiene que trascender tiene que tener una
visión una misión
cuál podría hacer esa misión tal vez que
vivamos en armonía porque si nos
educamos
y no nos sirve en nuestra educación
entonces como dice un maestro mío lo que
nos sirve para vivir no sirve para nada
si no estamos educando para vivir bien
no está sirviendo pero nuestra palabra
construye y la música es un vehículo
maravilloso y extraordinario para
generar mejor pensamiento mejor
sentimiento sabían ustedes que están era
violinista sabían ustedes que leonardo
da vinci era músico que no era iletrado
que tenía muchos problemas pero hoy en
día lo hubieran pastilla probablemente
pero uno de los mayores genios no daba
no pegaba una fue en sus último mentos
de la vida que tuvo éxito
la mamá de einstein aseguraba que todo
lo que él había descubierto era porque
era músico abrahán lincoln estudiaba
músico aristóteles dice que es imposible
la educación sin una educación formal de
la música porque porque la música es la
única actividad que hace que los dos
hemisferios cerebrales trabajen en
conjunto ninguna otra
pero no le hemos dado importancia
ahorita estamos yendo
un instrumento como éste que se llama el
com vean qué interesante un instrumento
tan antiguo se ha estudiado que produce
en materia gris en el cerebro casi que
basado en eso deberíamos tener un gol en
cada aula empezar con eso y cerrar con
eso
pero vean lo que hace el sonido por
favor conmigo todo el mundo ponga sus
manos en el cuello
y por favor perciban con los dedos de
las manos con la totalidad de la mano
vayan profundo
todo el mundo conmigo
va a ser la letra como un gran color
recibiremos y hacemos la
[Música]
les miramos de nuevo
otra vez un poquito más fuerte
[Música]
y lo que fuerte se siente acá saben
porque no solo porque hay resonancia
sino porque aquí está nuestro sistema
nervioso y para estudiar para aprender
tenemos que estar relajados y si uno que
todos pasamos por un sistema de más bien
te tensión miedo a fallar miedo a las
malas notas miedo al regaño de los
profesores miedo a quedarme miedo a mis
papás porque me van a castigar qué clase
de entorno vivimos que no nos acordamos
del 90% de lo que aprendimos en el
colegio
ninguno de nosotros puede decir cómo me
gustó el colegio ame estar ahí muy pocos
pueden decir eso
tenemos que cambiar la forma en que
aprendemos convertirnos en discípulos
gozar gozar la oportunidad de aprender
la música es un vehículo yo quisiera que
antes de las clases la gente escuchara
música para que se relajara para que
pudiera disfrutar lo que aprenden los
estudiantes deberían con estudiar con
música claro música que fomente el
aprendizaje pero es mucho más profundo
porque conocimiento con emoción
seres humanos exitosos
por favor conmigo otra vez aquí
hay una letra que usamos cuando nos
dicen nos hace una pregunta y
necesitamos pensar qué letra usamos la m
verá
[Música]
pregúntense porque es el subconsciente
usando un sonido para relajarme y pensar
mejor buscar la respuesta entonces
conmigo respiramos
[Música]
bueno él
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]